citizens of the reject Nation we got
ourselves a Godzilla X Kong trailer
today how are you I'm pretty good how
are you I'm excited man last night my
wife had the uh my wife had the choice
of what do we watch and she chose
Godzilla versus Co so I in a super big
mood right now sized mood for Godzilla X
Kong the new Empire so you know what to
do leave a like on this video people we
got so much stuff coming out so make
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell enough chitchat let's
get to
it
2001 seismic activity Monarch Legacy of
monsters most of human
civilization Egypt the wonders of the
world that Li life could only
exist on the surface of our
planet uhuh I back aall sounds like
looks like Transformers tra yes rench
the
Fallen he's got armor it looks like
Transformers yeah what else were we
wrong
about you wrong Kong
oh oh you got that that music back just
like uh the last one you come on in
yes more secret oh they got new ships
yeah they got Anime ships she got short
hair now was
that
Caesar oh who's this little guy son of
Kong is that danad
stens the guest
reunion
po could have done
this I'm so
[Music]
excited it's
personal the rise of a
partnership wow is that
Gia he's back yes my dude stop this on
his
own he won't be alone wow the visuals
are so much more oh wake him up that my
be is that a different creature is that
Godzilla
whoa what
what
damn oh my goodness oh damn
dude
Holy balls yeah this looks wild oh my
God this is going to be the greatest
movie of all time buddy
cops is that a mini Kong the son of
[Laughter]
Kong oh my God I am so jacked right now
I am excited but you know what I'm most
excited for them new monarch suits that
they got rocking on man most definitely
drips on those Monarch agents looking
fly is so important and you know what
man they could look even more fly this
holiday season with some reject apparel
at
www. reation shop.com where you get
shirts like this one of Pedro Pascal
Child Protection Services you can
support just being a citizen of the
reject Nation with a real reject ticket
Stu sure but we also got space babies of
the Galaxy who influences The
influencers Watchman inspired America's
ass homelander shirt with his Riff on
Captain America you know how it goes and
then we got bat verse we got a whole
bunch of other te's and whatever you
decide to get is a great way to support
the channel it's a great gift to get
people for this holiday season we make
sure the shirts feel comfortable and
it's an excellent way to support the
channel my personal favorite way you can
do it all right let's talk about this
man okay wow all right well I feel like
uh Adam Wingard is the director yes yeah
I think Adam winguard you know he got
his feet wet with the last movie I think
he did an excellent job when it came to
everything involving the Kaiju and now
after last night I will have seen the
last movie three times at this point and
I still think like man he really
excelled when it came to everything with
the monsters and especially bringing
Kong a genuine personality and a
character to connect with and you can
just tell that he's got a refined skill
I heard that there's going to be many
sequences in this movie one that might
be up to close to 10 minutes where it's
just going to be visuals of just the
animation fights just the monster not
just no I mean just like scenes like a
scene not even just a fight scene okay
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah sure because
like the best parts of that movie are
the scenes with Gia and Kong and
Godzilla stuff that doesn't really have
anything to do with the humans you
know yeah she's the bridge between the
humans that nobody cares about and the
bustard well it looks like here that
we're going to have um I I heard that
the the name of the villain and I could
be wrong about this I heard that the
name of that ape villain I is called
scar King oh um I could be wrong could
be wrong stellin scar King stellen Scar
King and that so he will be the main
villain and that he could have some type
of other creature that's a about the
extent of this the rumors I've heard
sure this new ape monkey so I feel like
we'll have two different things here it
looks like we're going to have that bad
guy to contend with that Kong finds in
Hollow Earth scar King which we will
need the aid of this evolved Godzilla
with yeah and then there's this other
tribe which I imagine by the end Kong
would be like the leader ruler over the
yeah that's because he found a thing to
be a king over we in Hall Earth the last
movie he just found a chair to sit on
with an A and now he's going to have
people to rule my wardr my accessories
now I need my kingdom subject whatever
where I go this Godzilla wants to fight
me where I go we finally got peace and
now I need to R over some people um and
then with an age of like having Monarch
Legacy of monsters with having a
Godzilla minus one and then having this
franchise to get an involve Godzilla
with a distinguished look one that is
very much disting distinguished uh I I
think is a really smart call but this
just looks more like they they're
zeroing in and focusing in on everything
that made the last movie work so well
they're getting they're going to see
they're going to spend most of our time
in the hollow Earth we're going to spend
most of our time with the actual Kaiju
and creatures uh this the scale and
Threat Level looks massive and epic uh
I'm I'm really I really love Godzilla
versus the only thing I don't really
like is the Billy Bobby Brown and Brian
Tyre Henry story outside of that wow
yeah I know it's unpopular opinion
nobody shares opinion I mean I don't
mind the the Monarch characters but but
them I was like that's the plot one I'm
really not a big fan sure but everything
else I really love I think it's such a
fun movie and and this I imagine will
while it's like a serious trailer I I
feel like they'll probably go even uh
they'll lean into some of its more like
strange wackiness at the last movie had
yeah I mean I have hope for that because
I feel like Adam Wingard of all the
monsterverse movies managed to find like
an agreeable tone uh mashup between yeah
stuff that is like endearing and
actually touching with Kong and Gia and
and that side of the story but then you
know bringing us the requisite sense of
fun that Adam Wingard usually kind of
has on his projects and stuff like that
and yeah this seems like something where
look so good look at the visual that
that like Fusia you know glow in the
back plates and stuff like that and you
know like every Godzilla movie there's
always some kind of twist on the look
and the power set and all that stuff and
and what it means when the you know the
the um Atomic breath is especially so
it's so hot now it's purple or something
like that just them running together
well he's got his Thanos glove his he's
going to snap half of so it must be
something that Monarch helped design for
him I imagine or or is it some type of
ancient weapon that they used prior
because it looks like something monar D
that will get you closer to your
Transformers crossover hent Tech I mean
he always needs some type of tech thing
right but but last time now he need it
shows the Threat Level for them to be um
yeah for them to have to really partner
up yeah no 100% you know after the
uneasy Alliance last time and the
respectful kind of sendoff but like this
the last movie had those I'm curious
about how much this is going to resemble
some of the movies it's reminding me of
because the last one you know obviously
with Mecha Godzilla and stuff like that
you have the whole like Batman v
Superman element and in this I'm getting
shades of like stuff that reminds me of
both the early phases of 2001 but also
more over the recent like Planet of the
Apes movies where I'm like is Kong gonna
be dealing with some kind of like
factional dispute that he needs to yeah
like you know whoop this scar King's ass
to settle uh I mean for Godzilla to get
involved and to be teaming up with Kong
be Earth threatening something tells me
that the scar King and Godzilla maybe
have a got beef yeah that maybe there's
a history with them you know CU every
the mon the KA you all come from Hollow
Earth so maybe there is a history there
that makes Godzilla be like that son of
a is B I got to get it on the
action he's he's going after my My
Little My little monkey my My Gods
son I like the look of uh son of Kong if
that's who that is uh I think it's just
another tribe okay I I was they don't
look like Kong I think I think it's
going to become like he's going to be
like again I imagine is going to be like
surrogate cuz they don't look at all
like they're the same ty not all apes
are the same joh yeah I'm sorry I didn't
mean to be a big it against no it look
it looks like that's a completely
different tribe and then and then
there's going to we're going to see
other members of this tribe yeah and
then Kong's going to watch over them and
then it looks like too that there's
elements here where you're going to see
are Gia's people from The Hollow Earth
as well because you got all these like
humans in a different civilization here
as well so it looks like you're going to
see that there must be yeah they must be
the special people who live in uh
whatever in shangi you know they live in
uh I keep want to call it conun but
that's not the right property right yeah
maybe they are some kind of special race
who are bonded with these creatures and
and you know Bound by duty to protect
them or whatever um but dudes I love
this trailer uh so much I am so jacked I
am jacked I really love this yeah no
absolutely this has all the fun and and
like promise of wacky you know more
broad expansions and it's fascinating to
see what we America choose to do to up
the ante while you know you also have
immediate examples of what Japan's doing
to up the ante and it's just a fun time
to be a Godzilla fan G yeah I agree John
guys what you think about the trailer
leave your thoughts down below be sure
to subscribe leave a like I got to get
this video to deliver to all yall and uh
support us at reject Nation shop.com
let's get to
[Music]
it